hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting matchup from yesterday's
protest League it's a Magnus Carlson
versus the youngest player ever to
achieve the title of Grand Master that
is abhimanyu Mishra he achieved it in
2021 in June uh at the age of 12 months
12 years uh four months and I believe 30
days
um 25 days to be exact uh so um 12 years
uh four months and 25 days and he beat
uh kariakin's record that he held ever
since 2002 so that is an incredible feat
in itself but in a recent interview he
announced that he would also like to be
the youngest the Grand Master uh to to
ever achieve um uh the the title of
world champion uh so uh that's a lot a
lot of work to be done there but you
know what better way to do it than to
play a game against the Magnus Carlsen
so even if he does become uh the uh the
classical world champion at some point
uh one day he will not be facing Magnus
Carlson for the title as we all know
Magnus Carlsen
the the decided not to defend his uh
title against the anupon issues so uh
we'll see we'll see how that goes for
him but for now he gets a chance to take
a crack at the world champion uh in a
rapid game in the protest league so
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with C4 he goes for the English opening
but we quickly transpose into the Carl
Khan C6 Ponte E4 yeah basically the
accelerated fan of attack and now D5 uh
striking in the center we have C capture
C captures and now uh mostly everyone
plays ecaptress on D5 here it's uh it's
a move that uh uh it's just pretty
automatic but here Magnus plays E5 it's
a move that has been played only a few
times uh and interestingly
um well uh but his trainer uh Steven
Augustine played it a few times himself
so it's his former trainer of course not
his current trainer but still very
interesting maybe Magnus picked it up
from him so here Bishop to F5 uh you
want to get the bishop out of the uh out
of his lair before playing E6 Pawn to D4
we have E6 and now Bishop to D3
challenging the bishop and here Bishop
captures uh is is a move that has been
played before but here uh Mishra played
Knight to this sorry not Knight to D7
Knight D7 and it is now as of move six
that we have a completely new game so
very very interesting stuff Knight to C3
and now Knight to D7 and this Knight to
D7 is an uh in Precision to say the
least because look at this uh king
that's completely boxed in here Magnus
just plays Knight to B5 and now you
don't have a an opportunity to to trade
now because Knight to D6 will just be a
smothered mate so here first Mishra has
to play Knight to C6 to create some
breeding room for the king also the
bishop is covering D6 now but now Magnus
ruins his Pawn structure Bishop captures
e captures and Knight to D2 it's all
very unorthodox way uh to treat an
opening but maybe it's exactly what uh
sure I wanted to to go for Bishop to B4
with check Bishop to D2 and here we have
castles Magnus captures on B4 Knight
captures and now castles there's uh
always time to bring the Knight to D6 so
Knights the B6 and Knight to D6 Magnus
gets his Knights to this beautiful
square and he puts pressure on the B7
Pawn so Queen D7 uh I'll be defends this
we have Queen to B3 goes for the Knight
and now Knight back to C6 we have Rook 8
to C1 uh getting the Rook to the only uh
open file and now Rook a to B8 this
Knight cannot move as um Magnus is
really attacking that B7 Pawn so uh
abhimanyu needs the defender we Rook
after D1 and now Knight the C8 just
going for trades here and Magnus
declines the trade he goes back Knight
to B5 it would have been interesting if
Magnus just went for an all-out trade
here would not get Knight captures on F5
uh Queen captures and The Rook captures
on C6 as The Rook can be it is
undefended but maybe thought that this
wasn't
you know a sufficient attempt maybe it's
not a a serious a try then what he went
for he's up upon uh maybe you know two
two against one here on the queen side
but there's the C Pawn so it's not maybe
not all that great so instead he goes
Knight to B5 we have Ponte A6 Knights
the C3 and now Knight ate the E7 uh we
have Knight to F4 now Magnus shifts his
attention to the uh to the D5 pawn and
now Rook after d8 the pawn is now
defended but now Knight to a for here
Magnus wants to bring the Knight done uh
either B6 or C5 so B6 stopping that and
now Queen to E3 which is a very nice
move uh interestingly uh you cannot go
for Knight cap for some B6 it looks like
there might be something there the
problem is there's Queen to A7 and now
just nothing works even if you go for
some tricky stuff like Rook captures and
C6 Knight captures and Knight captures
and D5 to create this massive Center
here after Rook captures Queen captures
and queen capture some B6 this is simply
not enough uh for example 97 attacks the
queen uh even if you capture him with
checking a f8 and black will always just
be up a piece there's no sufficient
compensation there so instead after B6
we have Queen to E3 by Magnus and now
Rook D to C8 we have Ponte H4 preparing
to go after the black king also creating
some room for the white king here Knight
the d8 now Shifting the Knight over to
E6 also offering a trade on the C file
so magnet straight we have root captures
Queen captures The Rook has to remain
and the B file to guard the B Pawn so
Knight to C3 now going once again after
the D5 pawn queen to D7 and now Queen to
F3 and now the pawn cannot be defended
Magnus will now surely win this Pawn
which is probably what he saw when he
decided not to go for that exchange line
that we've covered Knight to E6 we have
Knight F captures and D5 Knight captures
Knight captures one would expect also
Queen captures for Magnus and going for
for Queen trade but he decides to keep
the Queens on the board Knight captures
on D5 38 attacks the Knight Knight
captures on B6 now goes after the queen
and queen to B5 now
pressures the Knight also puts pressure
on the B2 Pawn also the D4 Pawn is being
threatened so here Queen to B3 another
thing Magnus could try is this very
aggressive D5 move which uh results in
Queen captures D captors Rook captures
with check Queen captures and F
characters and here okay Magnus is up
upon he can play Queen to D7 uh he does
have two to one on the queen side he has
a very active Queen the black king is
completely uh useless and uh it would be
it would be a fine position for him but
instead he went Queen to B3 he offers a
queen trade this way and now uh Abby
should definitely capture on B3 for
example Queen captures a captures Rook
captures on D4 now everything just gets
traded off captures captures and you get
uh
uh this position where Magnus is up upon
but it's it's a double B Pawn so nothing
um nothing spectacular uh but instead
after Queen to B3 Knight captures and D4
was played now attacking magnus's Queen
here Magnus traits Queen captures eight
characters and King to F1 of course you
don't want to see Knight's D2 checkfall
by Rook captures on D1 so Magnus needs
to go King to F1 we have King to f8 Abby
also starts bringing the king into the
game uh and now Pawn to A4 just creating
a pass Pawn on the queen side B captures
an A4 now Knight captures an A4 and King
to E7 with Knight to C5 and now Rook the
C8 attacking the Knight and the Magnus
of course cements it with Pawn to B4 uh
Knight the C6 now going after the the B4
Pawn but luckily there's a rook to D7
with check King to E8 and now there are
a couple of moves that white could play
but there is only one way uh that you
will win the game so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
winning for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
that you have to clear the the seventh
Rank and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Pawn to E6 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this uh it's the only move that wins and
you can't really ignore this uh even if
you play something like Knight to d8
okay you you can defend F7 uh still just
it captures Knight captures white will
move the Knight and there's no move you
can make here you can't move the Knight
because the pawns hang uh The Rook
doesn't really have anywhere to go if
the king moves then you are prone to all
sorts of checks so this would be a very
very slow death for black but uh you
know slowly but surely Magnus will bring
his King over to E6 and suffocate the
black king so instead after E6 I'll be
tried F captures and E6 but now Rook
captures on G7 and here I was extremely
low on time Magnus had some four and a
half minutes on the clock uh Mishra had
like uh like a second when he played his
next move uh he played Knight captures
on B4 but now uh he missed that the D7
Square was covered by the Knight which
means that Rook to Jade just wins the
road because now the king does not have
access to d8 or D7 so King to F7 was
played Rook captures on C8 and he was in
this position on move 41 that uh
abhimanyu Mishra resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
a really fun game in in a really funky
line that went from English to The
Accelerated Pawn of attack to this very
very weird position that after Knight E7
has never been reached again already on
move six fun game it could have gone
either way but it's Magnus who came
comes up on top in the end but very
nicely very nicely played by the
youngest Grand Master ever uh ABI Manu
Mishra so there we have it I hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
randompile.net Glenn Beaton Chris Foster
Bernardo morani and funky monk for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day